[Music]
use the camera controls to move the
camera around your layer
now use the rotate controls to rotate
the camera
[Music]
you can use the zoom controls to zoom in
and out
use the tilt controls to tilt your
camera
hold on who do you think you are giving
me instructions like that
i i'm here to help
by telling you exactly what to do next
in a friendly
and helpful manner
but you are here to do everything i say
correct step one
tell us what you want and the minions
will do it
we're eager to please
uh and also be eager to live
please stop looking at me like that
new main objective available
your layer will be much more impressive
once it has more rooms
open the build menu
you need a place to store your gold
select the vault icon
paint tiles over the highlighted area
this will be where we'll build your
vault
gold pallets will increase the amount of
gold you can keep in your lair
[Music]
it's best not to leave your gold sitting
in the open
add a door to your vault
wait for your minions to install the
door before moving on ordered furniture
must first be collected from the depot
under the helipad
[Music]
new main objective available
now your gold is safe let's add another
room to the lair
minions need to rest after a day of evil
deeds
let's build a barracks
beds give minions places to sleep when
their vitality or morale start to run
low
[Music]
items can be rotated freely with the
rotate controls
items that need to be placed next to a
wall will automatically rotate
place some beds on the other side of the
barracks
[Music]
doors can be placed between walls
they always need a gap of four tiles
open the systems menu
objectives will help pave the way to
world domination
[Music]
optional objectives will give you small
frequent challenges
collect this one now for a reward
come back here often for main objectives
side stories and optional objectives
food is an essential part of any minions
diet
without it they'll become more unhealthy
and less intelligent
much less intelligent
build a mess hole
you can rotate any item in your layer
you can also move them after they've
been constructed
basic food counters restore minion
smarts and vitality and stop stomachs
from rumbling
[Music]
new main objective available
it seems we're low on power
let's fix that before continuing
build space for a power station
you can place this way you like but be
careful as it will be a tempting target
for enemy agents
[Music]
generators power items in the layer
without it almost nothing will function
be careful as enemy agents will attempt
to sabotage your generators if they find
them
it sure is dark isn't it
are you scared
no
me me neither
optional objective complete
[Music]
new optional objective available
defeated agents lie in body bags on the
floor causing minions to lose morale if
they get too close
build an incinerator in your power
station to dispose of them
[Music]
new main objective available
open the character selection panel then
select the evil genius portrait to
highlight and follow your evil genius
with the evil genius selected interact
anywhere in the highlighted area to move
your genius
[Music]
very well
you need a control room to send minions
into the world
let's lay down a plan for one
evil minds think alike
[Music]
so
radio repeaters provide broadcast
strength
allowing us to maintain criminal
networks across the globe
[Music]
the more broadcast strength you generate
with your radio repeaters the more of
the world you can infiltrate
for now let's just infiltrate a little
bit
[Music]
so
new optional objective available
heads to the world stage
each of the highlighted regions is an
excellent place to start your journey
towards world domination
select a suggested region or any other
region if you know what you are doing
and scout it to establish a criminal
network
you can speed things up by selecting
fast forward at any time
[Music]
once built you can use our criminal
network to run schemes in this region
time is money
yes
[Music]
uh
i'm all packed boss send me into the
world and i'll come back with plenty of
gold
come back you think you're coming back
no i'm not having you coming back here
tracking justice all over the place like
mud they'll follow you right to my door
and then where would we be
take a little gold for yourself then
send the rest back here
use your share to live a quiet life
or else
minions will travel to the world and run
any scheme you select
you will receive small amounts of gold
as they progress
new main objective available
a prison will make for the perfect place
to hold your enemies before questioning
them
[Music]
so
these holding cells hold one prisoner
each
if you don't have any free cells your
minions can't capture people
[Music]
this interrogation chair is built
we can use it to make prisoners tell us
their secrets
new main objective available
experiment with interrogating agents you
never know what secrets you will uncover
[Music]
new optional objective available
new main objective available
select a scientist scheme
special schemes are often highlighted on
the world stage with colored signs
keep your eyes open for these important
schemes
[Music]
optional objective complete
new optional objective available
[Music]
a scheme has succeeded
once complete the scheme will yield to a
fresh-faced scientist
[Music]
optional objective complete
i'm ready to uncover the mysteries of
the universe for you boss
what do you want me to research
interesting word research
implies you are searching for something
a second time you better not be charging
me for the same work twice
your new scientist appears to believe
that we can use a training room to teach
our slack jawed minions how to do
specialist jobs
get one built and you can find out for
sure
[Music]
each specialist minion type requires a
trainer of its own
request a scientist trainer
once built you will be able to instruct
your minions to train as scientists
having more scientists will speed up
future research
new optional objective available
[Music]
so
new main objective available
with the correct training furniture
built in your training room you can
request that your minions train to
become specialists
head to the minion training screen to
request training of some new scientists
you should request two scientists to be
trained
thankfully we already have a scientist
so training another should be a breeze
if for some reason one of your
scientists disappears
another minion will instantly train
until they have this many in your layer
again
useful
your workers will start to train
automatically
they'll learn faster if another minion
is able to teach them
[Music]
your minions will need somewhere to
perform their research
plan a laboratory
[Music]
a whiteboard is essential for scientists
to perform research
as we unlock more potent research we'll
need to provide them with more advanced
equipment
[Music]
so
new optional objective available
[Music]
so
new main objective available
open the research screen and take a look
at all the diabolical opportunities
choose any research project and set your
scientists researching it
we suggest increasing your minion
capacity but ultimately the choice is
yours oh wise one
[Music]
research has begun
research takes time and our scientists
will let us know when it's complete
head back to the layer to continue your
world domination
you are blessed with powerful abilities
which can be used to further influence
those around you
select your genius
notice how your minions come running to
help
this can be very useful when you want to
give the productivity in your lair a bit
of a boost
if your genius isn't in a busy room try
moving to somewhere there are jobs to be
done and try again
side stories are objectives that will
unlock powerful additions to your empire
you should start by learning about how
guards work
once you have done that you can learn
about new minion types
what we need is a little more muscle
around here you there how much can you
lift
about 70 kilos on a good day 80 if i use
both hands
uh-huh and how many bullet wounds can
you take before you give up
one
maybe two my point exactly get out there
and find someone strong learn their
secrets
many objectives require you to send
different types of minions to run
special schemes
let's go to the world stage to get
started
one of the highlighted schemes is near
one of your criminal networks
you can send minions to complete the
scheme now or you can search the globe
for an alternative
optional objective complete
[Music]
research has been paused
your minions have kidnapped a specialist
once they're in a holding cell you can
choose to interrogate them
[Music]
so
research has resumed
[Music]
an intruder has been captured
select the holding cell and then select
escort prisoner
after that select the interrogation
device
for now that's the interrogation chair
[Music]
an intruder has given us their secrets
with all these new recruits you should
expand your training room to make space
for all those exotic training machines
[Music]
new optional objective available
so
[Music]
new main objective available
guards are important to the security of
your lair but can disappear quicker than
a dry martini
build two guard trainers so that your
minions can top up their wilting numbers
post haste
[Music]
once constructed we can use the minion
training screen to request our minions
start their training to become fully
fledged guards won't that be nice
[Music]
new main objective available
head to the minion training screen to
request some advanced minions
we have two guard trainers so set your
lair to always try and maintain four
guards
when they are defeated in combat your
minions will quickly train and create
new guards to take their place at your
side
wow
look at them go
i could do that but i don't want to
guards are just one of the muscle type
minions you will be able to find as you
expand your empire
[Music]
new optional objective
i'm thinking i need to be here
faster faster
[Music]
new main objective available
now that you have enough guards to
support them request some guard posts
towards the entrance to your lair
[Music]
during high alert your guards will
diligently man these aptly named guard
posts
[Music]
your scientists have made a breakthrough
not enough gold to complete this
construction
[Music]
we have picked up some movement near
your lair
keep an eye out for incoming agents
[Music]
guards like to use their muscles to
defeat agents
tag this agent for swift termination
new optional objective available
[Music]
i need that intruder an intruder in my
lair
finds them and eliminate them
turn on high alert
and watch as your minions scurry to deal
with any tagged agents they find in your
lair
[Music]
hey
uh
[Music]
nicely done
turn off high alert
once you have finished dancing
fisticuffs are an occupational hazard
for your guards and lowers their
vitality
a short stay in the infirmary can patch
them right up
[Music]
an intensive care pod like this can
officially deal with 1 000 boo-boos per
hour
actual results may vary
[Music]
if a minion's vitality gets too low they
will go to the closest infirmary to
attempt to heal
if their vitality reaches zero then it
might be time to hire a new minion
[Music]
so
research has begun
[Music]
a new criminal network has been
established
[Music]
new optional objective available
well done
your horde of guards will be the first
line of defense and help to keep the
riffraff out collect to the completed
side story to continue your world
domination
now this is more like it tell me what do
you bench press
the biggest one
right okay not quite what i expected how
many bullet wounds would it take to kill
you
the biggest one
[Music]
are you okay wait i don't want to know
you are hired
[Music]
one down two to go
select a new minion side story from the
objective screen
[Music]
another group of agents can't a genius
with a dubious criminal past purchase an
exotic lair in peace anymore it's
probably all the helicopters they'll be
wondering what we're doing out here
that's why i chose this location it has
the perfect cover operation even if it
is abandoned i think the problem is that
it's abandoned boss
not many people visit and abandoned
anything
for once you make a good point very well
hire some staff dress them well teach
them to cheat at roulette
many objectives require you to send
different types of minions to run
special schemes
let's go to the world stage to get
started
one of the highlighted schemes is near
one of your criminal networks
you can send millions to complete the
scheme now
or you can search the globe for an
alternative
[Music]
your minions have kidnapped a specialist
once they're in a holding cell you can
choose to interrogate them
that scheme has succeeded
[Music]
a scheme has succeeded
research has resumed
[Music]
new optional objective available
a new criminal network has been
established
we've got a new prisoner
select the holding cell and then select
escort prisoner
after that select the interrogation
device
for now that's the interrogation chair
an intruder has given us their secrets
interrogation has revealed to us how to
build new training furniture
build the new item in your training room
[Music]
research has been paused
so
[Music]
new main objective available
head to the minion training screen to
request some advanced minions
request the amount of this specialist
you want in your lair
your minions will always try to keep to
this number
[Music]
your workers will start to train
automatically
they'll learn faster if another minion
is able to teach them
a scheme has succeeded
[Music]
so
you